hello everyone and welcome back to the
legends of chess tournament where we
have the first game featuring an actual
legend it is Boris Gelfand facing
Dingley Hren and I would just like to
say that before this game the two of
them faced each other eight times and
those eight games were classical games
and in those eight games being won three
games of Boris one one and four games
with were drawn however this is a rapid
end we'll see what what happens here now
this is a I think this is the best game
of day one some of the games are still
being played but I don't see them being
more exciting than this one I could be
wrong though it has happened before so
without further ado let's check it out
and oh yeah I would just like to mention
one more thing there is a link in the
description below do click on it it's a
it's a really an awesome chess music
video by Adam Genesis he played a bullet
game against me and made it into a music
video so I'm not gonna spoil it too much
for you but do check it out you know
Adam he makes some of the thumbnails
we've enjoyed on this channel lately and
he's also doing this member of our chest
manga team so do check it out a link is
in the description now getting back to
this game Boris opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 from from being c4
we have g6 and Knight to c3 ending goes
for d5 and we have the groom full
defense we have characters captures and
E 4 bodies goes for the main line Knight
captures seek actress and now Bishop to
g7 with Bishop to c4 by boris of course
going for the main line and now c5 ding
strikes in the center as you do want as
you have all of these nice pieces here
attacking the center so 92 boris
develops while adding a defender to the
center and the knights the c6 think
again develops by attacking the center
Bishop e3 boris does the same as this is
the theme of the main line of the groom
felled and now both players castle so
castles castles and here the the most
common way to continue developing these
Bishop g4 and Queen to c7 however Dean
goes for a sort of an offbeat line would
be 6 prepares to develop the bishop to
b7 bring the rook into c8 plain not nice
to a5 and go for the usual green folds
stuff so Queen to d2 by Boris that makes
sense that makes this battery at some
point you might want to exchange a white
dark square bishop for blacks and Bishop
the b7 thing just continues developing
with rook F 2 d1 and rook to c8 now
binding we look at the c1 by Boris now
the development of his species has been
completed and east six now numbing the
the power of the lights work the shop
and also fighting for the d5 square now
and now when the rook moved to c1 you
know you're no longer really worried
about any dark square Bishop action you
want to play b5 at some point and claim
claim the center so here there is a move
Bishop to h6 this is a known movies
being played in the game laQuan lien
versus Alexander Bishop in the World Cup
2013 where long liam won a game against
goodie shop with this with this move
however guys one goes for Bishop to g5
he attacks the Queen it's a bit of a
different idea not such a forcing line
and it is already as of move 14 that we
have a completely new game so let's see
what happens here
Queen d7 biting and now just age for
Boris even though he's not very active
lately he's been following the
development of chess theory via of
course so we watch as 0 and alpha 0 and
he knows that you should always push her
age pawn to victory
so with Knight to a5 the usual room
filled stuff putting your knight on the
rim attacking the Y squared Bishop and
Bishop back to d3 now and here Dean
takes this opportunity to trade some
pieces pawns in the center and trade off
some ropes so characters characters in
here we have rook captures in c1 rook
captures and rook the c8 with this move
ding now completely trade trades off
everything and is left with two with two
very nice bishops and a knight on the
rim but the knight can easily reach them
in the game so rough characters on c8 by
Boris
Queen captures on c8 and now h5 board is
continuous pushing the H pawn as that's
how modern chess is played we have night
the c-4 binding
bringing the right back into the game
hoping for a bunch of characters but of
course the Boris goes the Queen to see
one now with a double attack on the
night and now b5 later on in the game
ding will probably play a5 moved and I
play b4 and try and create a passed pawn
here
on the queenside as he does have the
two-to-one advantage on the queenside
however h6 from Boris now really in the
style of Lila and now push up the f8
keeping an eye on that h1 but also
controlling the the entire Queen side
now we have Queen to f4 by Boris and
ding now just place a success
there aren't any threats on the King
side it looks scary but it's really not
my dark square Bishop is taking care of
everything here so Knight to g3 Boris
brings the knight deeper into the attack
although it's not at all clear where the
night is going probably something like e
594 and something like Knight to f6
which would be ideal for white so nice
to d6 by being now putting pressure on
the e4 pawn if the knight moves or or
the bishop then the e4 pawn force
however he 5 I think was expecting the
e5 moved to come so with this he already
makes preparation for the night to come
to f5 which he does so Knight to f5 but
now Knight to f5 is not the most precise
way things should have gone 498 because
with Knight the f5 boris finds a
beautiful tactical shot Knight captures
on f5 sorry not Knight captures Bishop
character son f5 e characters on f5 and
now you will pause the video and try to
find well III
dare I say it the winning idea for white
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on keeping on attacking
in the greatest of styles and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's nice to h5 and now the problem with
the knight to h5 move is that you don't
really have the option of declining the
sacrifice because if you play something
and you don't really have that that many
moves to play I mean what can you play
if you play something like Bishop to d5
to block the pawn Knight f6 check just
for example just picks it up Bishop here
Knight f6 check picks up the bishop so
you could play something like a5 just
continue with your plan here but the
problem is Knight of 6 check King h8 and
now d5 the knife covers both of the
light squares d6 d7 is coming and is
game over for black so here being is
forced to capture the Knights og
captures on aged five and now Boris goes
for Bishop to f6 with the terrible
threat of Queen g5 or g3 check special
blocks and just Queen captures with
checkmate it's it's that easy and if
this was well any other player other
than ding I think that this would just
be game over however ding finds the only
move that allows him to continue the
game and that is Bishop to b4 but Bishop
to b4 only allows him to continue the
game it doesn't actually save the game
but there is only one move that wins now
for white so for the second time here
feel free to pause the video and do win
the game for Boris while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on spotting the only winning idea and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it's a three I know it's it's
always funny when such a move is the
only winning move but this is the case
here but just in case you're wondering
why not just Queen g5 check or something
like that we will explore the options as
this game is very very complicated for a
rapid game if this was a classical game
this would be so so crazy but point is
after Queen g5 check the problem is
after King f8 Queen g7 check King 2 EA 8
and Queen g8 check now the King doesn't
move and allows you to the capture the
bishop can just retreat via Bishop to f8
and now while you can't go Bishop g7
with a double attack King g7 just
defends everything and the problem is
Black is now up a piece and you you will
be able to like pick off this pawn
create a passed pawn but it will not be
enough to counter compensate for the 40
extra piece so here you could trade on
let's say with east 6 to force the King
away from the defense of the bishop to
win your Bishop back but now it's not a
problem as black can force force a draw
here let's see quickly one check King
here and you're gonna go Queen to f4
with check and now if this then just
captures and you're getting checkmate it
so you're forced to go back and then
again Queen here check engage to Queen
f4 check and so on so really really
awesome stuff after this Bishop to b4
move now the only thing that the does
win is a three because now the bishop
has no squares so if you go to f8 then
just Queen g5 check the King has
no no escape square on a face this is
covered this is covered this is covered
and now before is also covered and the
problem is with capturing that now Queen
g3 check just picks it up and yes it's
equal material regarding pieces what
with this coming with checking back to
g8 Queen g3 check now now it's a bit of
a different story because there is no
Bishop to f8 check and once this check
arrives you're gonna capture here with
check
you're gonna go King to c6 capture at
this point and now you have this
passport it's just completely winning so
here after Bishop to b4 the Boris
unfortunately did not go for a three he
played d5 similar idea giving up a pawn
for Queen characters here as now if
Boris wants to save the piece play
something like Queen a5 then well then
you really have problems then you can go
even Bishop to e7 block of the King and
then it was just completely winning so
here boar King immediately grabs this he
says oh this is just you know the saving
straw so Boris captures on before and
now Queen to c1 check biding King to h2
and now Queen to c4 going for a queen
trade but of course board is not
interested he still wants to either
checkmate black or pick up some of these
points create a passport and win the
game so King f8 ding doesn't allow this
to happen with check and now f3 taking
away some squares here and also blocking
the light square Bishop so for the
moment you you are doing well still here
as white so King e8 being looks for
sanctuary on the other side of the board
and now Queen a5 threatening Queen to d8
checkmate so of course the dink has to
go back and now quinta a3 by Boris
threatening this checkmate so Queen now
has to move away from the defense of the
a6 pawn Queen c7 and now Boris grabs it
with Queen captures on a6 and now it's
five points the five points but with
with dings King being so vulnerable here
it's very hard to say how this game will
end so here at Bishop the c6 biding not
allowing the the Queen to have any
access here access here and now Queen
back to a3 still keeping an eye on this
East seventh squares so the black King
for the moment cannot go anywhere
without the defending the e7 square
constantly so King the 7
borås starts running away and now queen
the f8 just still going for this h7 pawn
that that guy needs to be eliminated
with Bishop to d5 now guarding this pawn
you don't want to part with this point
either and now Queen to g8 going after
the point here but now Queen to c4 here
the problem is if you go after the h7
pawn that there actually is no problem
but it's hard to see that Queen captures
on h7 also wins because it's you you
have to see that after Queen hf4 check
and King here and Bishop captures and f3
you don't have to accept this and you
can just continue with your game and
black will not get a single temple here
to finish the job because you can just
continue harassing Queen e8 check and at
some point Queen b6 you will be able to
agree maneuver your Queen to the defense
overlooking let's say but she'll be a
check King a7 you're gonna go clean
these seven checking here Queen CI to
check you're gonna go King to a7 and now
finally Queen the c5 check and with this
Queen now guarding the f2 square you
will be able to bring the Queen back so
now let's say King b7 now you can
capture here and after this trap you
will be able to defend with the Queen
let's say Queen checks are gonna go here
check here check and finally block and
now with the extra piece of course you
are winning but not an easy thing to
spot with the seconds on the clock
ticking away
so Boris goes for Queen to d8 check
instead idea being that if King here
then this is just checkmate
so of course ding goes the other way not
getting check hated Queen King to c6 and
now comes Queen to see a to check with
King to b6 and now Queen captures on f5
now you have this this as an option in
the future you will capture this you
will capture this and hopefully
hopefully finally win the game so Bishop
e6 by ding and now not going for Queen
captures and h7 first boris goes for
Queen captures on h5 because now it is
just a very straight cover to draw you
cannot touch the h3 square so you have
to go back and I'll finish recheck you
can't go here because of Bishop c4 check
so you'd have to repeat moves like this
so here Boris instead captures the h5
pawn but now Queen to f4
with check King to g1 and now Quinta III
with check King each one and now Quinta
c1 with check now Dean grabs hold of
this diagonal after King H to check
Queen f4 check came to g1 Queen III
check King to h2 and Queen to f4 check
the players agreed to a draw rather it's
a draw by threefold repetition so really
in same game I don't know the exact age
of ding I think Boris is like at least
twice as all the Boris is 52 at the
moment but he doesn't seem to mind
playing rapid against when I one of the
best chess players in the world Ning
Lyra and member of the 2020 candidates
tournament and just showing him who's
the boss here
and Boris already won one game so he
actually had a chance in closing the
match this is actually game 3 so Boris
won one game into two our games were
drawn I don't know the results of Game
four as it's being played while I'm
recording this but you know anything can
happen and if it will be an interesting
and we will of course show it but I
thought even though we had a decisive
game in the match against on vs. thing I
thought that this one was just
incredible and I thought I should throw
this one because for a rapid game this
is this was just beautiful to watch but
you know I imagine extremely exhausting
to play but that's the game first game
by an actual legend Boris Gelfand so I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank do it Ron Carlo Botta
yeah me how our boy Nathan Wallace and
Tommy you internet for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here think of for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the legends
of chess tournament checking up on your
one of suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day and do check
out the chess music video in the
description below see you soon guys